[Music]
[Music]
my
family once a day genuinely sit there
for five minutes and make pretend one of
them got shot in the face
i probably once a week to four times a
week
sit there truly in the shower and try to
convince myself that i have
lost one of the five most important
people in my life
and that is the biggest thing i do that
leads to the biggest happiness i have
like what you didn't sell enough
earrings today
people lack perspective it's actually
remarkably easy
if it becomes the way you see the world
yeah ah
you know what i you know what after
standing in the shower this morning
and imagining one of my family members
being shot in the face
i realized i needed to fight in the
mortal kombat tournament
yeah to avenge them yeah exactly yeah
that's that's great advice how do you
it's just i made me feel worse honestly
now i feel like i'm
on the edge of something serious yeah
but um
it's just funny he like pictures one of
the way garyvee phrases things like just
the extreme ways that he puts things to
be more like
impactful or for clips to go viral for
you know to make more people
go like wow what an excellent point like
he could have just said hey like family
is what matters here
just if anything is bothering you just
remember like there's there are way
bigger problems that could happen to you
like you know there are there are people
right now with family members who have
cancer oh i don't remember
any of this yeah no imagine one of your
family members got shot in the
[ __ ] face imagine if your
parents didn't have a face anymore
picture your parents face right now and
replace it with a bloody mutilated mess
yeah yeah oh so why you didn't sell a
couple
programs today imagine your dad is
getting tortured
oh are you sad you're sad today
picture your grandma falling out of her
wheelchair
onto the street and getting ran over by
a bus and behind that
bus is a budweiser delivery truck and it
parks it right on her
dead ass corpse and one of the doors
flies up
and a whole case of [ __ ] cacti falls
out
just a tower of travis scott cacti
boom right on her [ __ ] limp corpse
and she explodes cat grandma juice
sprays all over the
buildings cactus jack pineapple flavored
seltzer
and dead grandma juice hits a
just a bus stop
full of people another drinking your
grandma
while you're sitting in your home sad
because you didn't sell a couple of
earrings
yeah dude it's crazy like at at any
moment
you know you can just picture
imagine your dog getting kicked down a
thousand stairs
pictures imagine you have kids you have
kids yeah yes i i do
i have i have a daughter okay imagine
your daughter gets taken
you ever seen that movie imagine that
happens to your daughter no it's your
daughter
and you can never get her back because
you don't have the skills cause you're
not liam neeson
and you're not a good enough parent
either you failed as a parent you're not
even liam neeson
how are you gonna save him you can't you
don't have the
technical skills
okay you know what i like to do i like
to picture my entire family getting
oh man
how old is that about to be
i don't even want to know that'll be
another family falling into a cement
truck
you know what i like to do every morning
i like to take my dick out onto the
counter
and pound it with a meat cleaver i like
to do that every single morning and i
pound that sucker
until it's raw and flat until i can't
even really recognize if it's a dick or
not anymore
so that when i so that when i go to work
and i gotta sell a couple earrings
i'm always reminded that it could be
better yeah
or it could be worse excuse me after
beating my [ __ ] to a pulp
with a meat cleaver with a literal meat
cleaver after putting my dick in my
semen dispenser with no lube and getting
it absolutely
beaten raw i go to work with that
non-functioning limp penis mickey mouse
or some [ __ ] dude
i'm gonna get my dick sucked off i'm
gonna get my dick sucked today
oh yuck you're so goofy
i got my penis stuck in the semen
collector today
man this thing sucks my dick better than
minnie mouse
doesn't even mickey mouse that's just a
guy just some guy on reddit
yeah what are you talking about it sucks
it better than minnie mouse
when does minnie mouse ever suck your
dick yeah man garyvee
always with the intense intense [ __ ] man
picture your family getting swallowed by
10 000 locusts
stung to death in the streets
you have to listen to their blood
curdling screams as they
as they're essentially tortured to death
as the romans hold you there and make
you
watch it because they've covered them in
honey
they're going to be consumed by this
army of locusts
then buried in a pit of frogs
that are all poisonous
some way you didn't sell a couple
earrings gary i just asked
about bitcoin
at the end of it you know so should i
buy it
[Laughter]
so is doge a good investment or is it
just a meme
imagine your dad's dick is covered in
locusts
what i don't want to picture that
you want to invest in doge right okay
imagine a single one of your balls being
sliced out of your ball sack
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
you're curious about crypto huh okay
picture the picture
let's say somebody twisted up your ball
sack enough times where you could just
snip that little
that little
[Laughter]
all right last one you're interested in
real estate
okay picture an elevator losing power
and crashing into the ground
a hundred stories collapsed onto your
grandma
grandma
and there's nothing oh my gosh
anderson get the lights back to regular
you can't do much more of that
ah [ __ ] that was damn damn
that might be the hardest bit we've had
in a minute
[ __ ] cody's moaning from
[Laughter]
twisted garyvee i'm about to light up a
cigarette after that
bro oh what's the [ __ ] word when
someone is just demanding
garyvee
garyvee is straight up demented dude
that dude is sick in the [ __ ]
sick holy [ __ ]
you're interested in technology imagine
you get the new
samsung nexus 12 and there's a video of
your daughter getting mutilated
[Laughter]
embedded into the phone
and it shipped worldwide so everyone has
a copy of this video
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
you like liquid death right
he's done he's tough
[Laughter]
that's
you